the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I promised everybody that we would have
the capability of testing a multi
Junction solar cell we've been working
so far with single Junction crystalline
silicon and just to refresh everybody
about what a multi Junction devices gate
is a high efficiency concept the
efficiencies that are obtained under
concentrated sunlight are above 40
percent now with some of these high
efficiency concentrator devices and the
again the way this concentrator device
works is if you have for example
germanium gallium arsenide indium
gallium phosphide stack three different
materials three different band gaps
ranging from somewhere in the range of
0.67 TV all the way up to a few evey the
largest band gap this place at the top
right because the short wavelength light
is absorbed by that one and the longer
wavelength lights go through and are
absorbed by the layers underneath so you
can think about this as blue orange and
red if you like to see things in colors
the short wavelength light being the
blue absorbed at the top the sunlight
obviously coming in through that side
through the top the middle cell
absorbing the light somewhere in the in
the middle of the solar spectrum in the
bottom cell into the Reds so the notion
is to have a device that is capable of
minimizing thermalization losses so the
short wavelength light instead of being
absorbed in a low bandgap material and
generating a ton of heat and in the
process is able to be absorbed very
efficiently a violet top cell and only
the longest wavelength light the lowest
energy light makes it down to the small
banget material underneath so this is
representative of the stack of materials
that we have I believe what we're going
to do is do a direct comparison of
silicon versus multi Junction is that
right
yeah so right now we have installed the
silicon devices those are the very
nicely encapsulated ones we had to
change the light source as you see now
we have a little bit of a flashlight
there why is that why did we have to go
from an LED a monochromatic light source
to a broadband flashlight
and it kind of defeats the purpose plus
the current outputs of these three
different cells have to be more or less
matched right so because they're
connected in series if you have a poor
performing cell or one component one sub
cell if you will that is generating a
small amount of current that will limit
the combined current output of that
entire stack good so why don't we go
ahead and connect them to our computers
we have our tech support staff available
on call who just walked out conveniently
but we'll be back momentarily
well connecting to our computers fire it
up and team up with somebody if you
don't happen to have a computer with you
we'll get this
we'll get this demo started so the
notion here is to first test the silicon
based device once we have a good working
IV curve out of the silicon based device
we'll talk about we'll take a pause
we'll talk about what we would expect to
see from the multi-junction device when
we hook that one up so when we go to it
and then give it a shot
so let me let me dive into what is
effectively our last in-class lecture
before we we are graced with with some
really nice at presentations I'm looking
forward to those so global trends what I
decided to talk to last day about really
we have a couple of topics left which we
don't have time to cover but we won't
have time to cover both we'll have time
to cover one but not the other and the
two topics are the future of R&D in
solar and the other topic is solar in
developing countries and I think both
are equally important I decided to pick
the former rather than the latter Global
Investments trends in solar and other
renewables what I wanted to do was
briefly walk through some of the recent
trends in R&D so energy companies
traditionally are not R&D spenders they
invest reinvest a very small fraction of
their profits in in R&D and research and
development and solar because it is far
from grid parity right now factor of two
factors three in terms of cost not price
cost we have to invest R&D to get the
cost down and this has both
manufacturing innovation and of course
engineering scientific innovation so
this right here is financial investment
in clean energy global trends by quarter
I've decided to compile as much data as
I possibly could into these slides so
that you can go out afterward if you're
really interested in the topic pursue it
further and what we see is as a rise
overall of investment in so-called clean
energy and by and large by the g20 these
are countries that have access to
resources to capital large larger GDPs
on average you also see a trend in in in
non g20 countries more recently an
uptick a recognition that this is an
important area and perhaps there's room
to play niches if you will that certain
countries can adopt that that would
provide a competitive advantage this is
an interesting chart as well
this shows the investment in believers
this is government R&D
this is financial sector investment only
excludes corporate and government R&D
small distributed capacity and both so
financial sector investment in the US
and China what we see in the u.s. is
relatively stable investment I picked up
in the mid-2000s but relatively stable
throughout and in China just a really
steady increase here of Varney funding
note the the role of the market in the
United States right around
oh five in oh six this was when the
price of PV began to plateau the cost
continued coming down but the price of
PV modules began to plateau because of
the silicon feedstock shortage right so
people saw opportunity here especially
the financial sector private capital and
said well hey if prices are remaining
high and the costs are coming down that
means her profit margin is growing this
is a good industry for us to get into a
high profit margin industry so there are
many folks getting in because of that
market condition some of them saw the
future of the market and said this is
trending towards commodities we have to
adopt that mentality and really squeeze
every penny out of our cost structure
that we can do and others went into it
thinking that this would be a bumper
crop a really high yield and investment
and then as the price that the margins
began to get squeezed they got scared
and some pulled out so it's an
interesting trend following the market
perturbations in the United States and
and having this this fluctuation and in
China from what I can tell discussing
with business leaders and politicians a
much more premeditated long-term
strategy saying this is a strategic
industry for our country we are going to
invest in it and this is of fundamental
national importance so a little bit of
difference in the investment strategies
of the to the EU is a little bit in
between a mixed bag again this uptick in
the middle of the 2000s but but a
continued investment in in PV and
renewables this shows the investment
type by sector broken down on the
right-hand side between the renewable
energy types
so you have wind solar other renewables
biofuels and so-called megawatts
so-called energy efficiency and on the
left-hand side we have the different
types of investment into a clean tech
and interestingly here in the United
States this in 2009 venture capital is
comprising a surprising total of the
investment in in renewable energy and in
terms of the sector itself we can see
solar here in the United States
comprising a large percentage again of
the total investment I want to bring
caution to one data point up there Spain
that was a little bit of a short-term
fluke the the Spanish government
instituted a feed-in tariff similar to
what Germany has has implemented but a
little less successfully let me dive
into the details Germany did a careful
market analysis was the first to move
into the space and began dominating the
market for PV 50% of P be installed so
if Germany set the price a little
differently the PV market would adjust
accordingly Spain a new entrant seeing
Germany success decided to replicate it
the first time they attempted a feed-in
tariff their feet in tariffs came in too
low and the market looked at Spain
shrugged their shoulders and continued
investing in installing in Germany the
second time they decided to come in they
put their feet in tariffs a little bit
too high and as a result market said
really you're kidding okay we go there
and install and there was a slosh of
modules over to Spain flooding the
market and over a period about a year to
two years they got much more than they
bargained for in other words they had
many many more and modules installed
than they had expected and now the
government has to pay out to these
module menu installed systems they have
to pay out a certain rate based on the
feed-in tariffs and it was more than
they expected to have to pay out then
the financial crisis hits so it was a
little bit of a disaster because they
ended up killing the program killing in
the process about 10 years of work to
design the program 10 years of
institution building to think about how
to create a feed-in tariff for Spain and
with without the desired result which
was a
slow steady increase of the photovoltaic
installations in Spain and enhance the
local industry so it was a little bit of
a flash in the pan a huge market that
burst very suddenly and then quickly
extinguished itself so it's a good
example of how not to perform a feed-in
tariff how not to design a feed-in
tariff so that's in 2009 that was a a
the end of the bumper year investment
Spain also did something that was pretty
nasty from a government policy point of
view they decided to retro actively
change their feet in tariffs so feed-in
tariffs is another is a contract between
the government or the utility and the
installer right saying that we will pay
a certain amount per year for a number
of years and to go back on that and
renege on on defeating tariff II that's
that's a no-no it undermines market
confidence so the the PV module prices I
just wanted to highlight this slide once
again to highlight the the market
conditions that are being experienced
right now we had an in the mid 2000s a
rise in or fairly steady prices and
meanwhile costs were coming down this by
the way is price but in thin films first
solar can tell these blue dots here
being crystalline silicon and the prices
remained fairly steady and then in the
say 2008 to 2011 prices have dropped
precipitously in 2011 numbers you're at
or slightly below a dollar so you can
see for somebody who is is being driven
by bar market conditions this is
extremely unsettling and that causes
capital to fluctuate back and forth now
the same thing what is happening here in
the solar modules the inverse is
happening in the installations so the
installers are seeing the price of their
modules go down and the price of their
installations declining steadily but but
but more or less staying fixed because
of the investment tax credits staying
fixed and so forth and us and utility
prices rising and so the installers are
saying hey this is great so their profit
margins are really big warning to
anybody - trying to get into the
- right now think carefully about these
market dynamics in the United States and
in Europe and how that will affect your
business right if you're trying to get
into the solar absorber as in module
manufacturing business or if you're
trying to get thing to the equipment
manufacturing business or in the
installation side on the grid think
about how these market dynamics are
going to affect your business as it
grows and tries to gain a foothold in
this environment it's a great time to be
a new installer company but in three or
four years when we're in an under supply
condition again and prices might even go
up what then right so think about these
these topics we're talking about our
renewable energy R&D and the technology
pipeline so it's important to recognize
the path that many of these new
technologies take to go from concept or
idea into full-scale manufacturing so in
general this is the path followed in the
United States and we have technology
research happening at places like like
this at MIT the rollout in other words
the installations and large-scale
manufacturing on the other side and
there are many funding sources available
for that not so much this last one here
in the United States but maybe in
Australia or Europe in select regions of
the US this technology development right
here in the middle has been what is
referred to as the valley of death does
anybody know why what what that means
valley of death what what is it
it's a pyramid it's difficult to get
funding from any source now imagine
you're a group of postdocs and students
in the lab you come up with a new fancy
technology and you can't quite get the
venture capital or private equity
necessary to kick off your company that
would be one that's a mini value of
death it's it's it's fairly avoided here
in the US a good ideas have a tendency
to get funded at that stage but if you
don't get funded then the postdoc gets
another position over here becomes a
professor at university across the
country the student goes off and does a
postdoc in another place and now all of
a sudden three five six months later the
venture capitalist whirls around to the
professor who still here at MIT and kind
of has a hollowed out group at this
point and says wow it's a great idea I'd
like to invest in it where's your team
yeah poof so that's one possible
mechanism were in technologies don't
make it forward right and so keeping the
team together is extremely important the
second valley of death can happen right
between technology development and
manufacturing and scale-up we've seen
some of these we've seen pictures of
some of the factories there around here
in the countryside these are it's
oftentimes tens more likely hundreds of
millions of dollars investments in
venture capital funds tend to be on the
order of hundreds of millions to a
billion dollars they don't like
investing in large asset goods they
don't like investing in factories they'd
rather invest in a small group of people
with the computers set in a garage maybe
put in a couple tens of thousands of
dollars and turn around profit of a few
million that's the type of investment
that makes a lot of sense for venture
capital when you start investing in
fixed goods in brick and mortar you need
other forms of financing right and some
countries around the world have been
very adept in providing this financing
China in particular has done a great job
at making that type of financing
available for companies that are small
and looking to expand but in the United
States it's very difficult to access
these essentially money from banks
especially for new technology the bank
will say well why am i investing in you
I could be investing in something that's
much more sure of a bet today's
technology instead of
besting something risky so the
government has stepped in with a variety
of programs to try to ease that
inefficiency in the market right and so
one of the means are our loans loan
guarantee program for example was one
mechanism there's a Sun path program
that's coming down the pipeline as well
so we have venture capital and private
equity but that can only take you so far
typically they invest a few tens of
millions of dollars in a few rare cases
a few hundreds of millions of dollars
but then they reach the end of their
credit line if you will they exhaust
their ability to invest and what's
needed to expand manufacturing is
typically on the order of hundreds of
millions to billions of dollars to reach
hundreds of megawatts gigawatt scale so
that's the second big valley of death in
the United States that exists and the
way cut some companies are transitioning
across that Valley they find a variety
of means some go overseas they say hey
the central bank of China is willing to
invest money in me I go there I set
manufacturing other companies small
companies might say well GE
you have a big Finance Group within your
big umbrella company why don't you buy
us and then we can gain access to
capital and expand our manufacturing
plant others form partnerships with with
banks it's it's a mixed mixed set of
business strategies but if you look
around at some of the startup companies
that are now entering small-scale
production there are this is where the
the business side of creativity comes in
play and that's where you really need a
good business developer at hand to
arrange those deals for you in terms of
where the money is in terms of clean
tech in general these are some figures
in terms of 2009 data I'm sure we can
get some more up-to-date figures as well
and in terms of growth and investment we
see some countries that might be rather
surprising right in terms of the
five-year growth of investment in
renewables obviously if you start from a
very small number you can grow pretty
quick in terms of percents but it's
still interesting to see the development
of some countries here this is sobering
so this is the
US government R&D by budget function 55
to 97 the most comprehensive data said I
could find I'm sure that there are
graphs that extend us into the future if
you happen to have one I'd be happy to
see it but the the basic story of this
graph is the following the lion's share
of R&D is going to the Defense
Department so the Army Research Office
Office of Naval Research DARPA that's
the Advanced Research Program a variety
of night-vision labs and so forth these
are a variety of defense Rd and there is
trickle-down there's some trickle-down
of technologies being developed in
defense into into civilian uses and so I
don't want to point to this and say it's
a boogeyman by no means but it does
indicate national priorities in terms of
R&D research the other big one is health
so NIH National Institutes of Health
that's growing and expanding it's very
easy to go to Congress people and
senators who might be advancing in their
years and say hey we need money for
Alzheimer's research or we need money
for cancer research right that's it's a
it resonates it's easy to convince
people of that energy is small
traditionally let me dive forward into a
this going a little bit further this
non-defense R&D funding pushed out to
2004 again you can see health really
driving things energy traditionally in
let's see the Jimmy Carter years right
around here it expanded a bit this was a
renewables burst that's where the
National Renewable Energy Laboratory was
founded originally called the solar
energy research institute or Cerie and
then got crimp down again and really
experienced a bit of a pinch in the u.s.
right when solar was really beginning to
take off in Japan so this is when a
solar cell production by shark was
really beginning to climb in the late
90s to early 2000s and then of course
Germany followed in the rest of the
world so we've been a little bit behind
step by step and the interesting thing
that many people have looked into is
what sort of correlation exists between
US government R&D spending
an output of new ideas and the output of
new idea is the metric that they're
using for this our patents so you could
dispute that you could say well patents
aren't the best indicator of new ideas
sometimes new ideas are of diffuse
benefit and they help all industries but
you can't really patent the idea fine
but this is I think the most
quantitative comparison that that folks
have performed this is an interesting
study where folks looked at the number
of patents granted and energy funds or
energy R&D funding and plotted as a
function of year and saw strong
correlation between uptick of national
priority and government funding and
innovation so this was the first wave of
innovation in in energy and an MPV
specifically in the late 1970s when the
OPEC oil crises hit in the United States
and there was a big push for a renewable
energy development yes question yeah
exactly yeah so these are are pushed
down and we can dive into patents
suggest for PV which is this graph right
here and it was an updated version of
that earlier study by Dan caman this
earlier study by Robert Margolis Robert
Margolis is now at NREL nationally Retta
National Renewable Energy Laboratory and
he works on market assessment there
oopsie Gregory nemyt was a student at
the time with Dan Kammen
produces wonderful continuation of the
study published a few years later and
again broke it down into specific
specific technologies including
photovoltaics and saw again some
correlation between the number of
patents and public R&D in the mid-2000s
this released the number of patents has
started to grow as startup companies got
into the fray remember when prices
stayed flat and cost continued coming
down and those margins increased the
bunch of players got into that space and
said we can make money so a number of
patents were filed a number of startup
companies got off the ground again
funding patent correlation for energy in
general I'd provide you the data you can
dive into it in more detail if you like
not only PV but other technologies
interesting global trends in venture
investing
venture investing is important for you
specifically it's one of the pathways to
get ideas out of the University and into
into a startup company we talked about
this so far and and okay so we're diving
a little bit deeper here this is for the
venture capital private equity financing
by sector in 2009 looking specifically
at solar in the United States comprise a
large fraction of it
solar continues to comprise a large
fraction of venture investment
surprisingly despite the market
conditions right now because folks
especially in the VC community are
looking at today's market as an
opportunity they think that if enough
people are scared out of the market that
they'll be able to remain there and pick
up the good ideas and if they're only a
little bit smarter than their
competition they can pick up the right
companies in the right sections of the
value chain maybe an equipment
manufacturer maybe an installer with a
new idea and avoid some of the pain
that's going on right now and wafer
fabrication and cell fabrication
upstream
this was the VC investment in solar
right here in those boom years that I
mentioned so during the years when
prices are started to plateau because of
the silicon feedstock shortage in the
mid-2000s you saw this massive uptick of
investment in venture capital funding
that scale is in millions of dollars
you're exceeding a billion dollars of VC
funding and solar in 2007 and that trend
continued in 2008 so it still to this
day where we're seeing hundreds of
millions of dollars plowed into solar by
venture capital funds it's interesting
really interesting the number of startup
companies in the United States has
proliferated there are I think somewhere
in the order of over 200 solar startup
companies worldwide there are a few that
have failed
so what Kahn does the last SV solar
Center giin opti solar Solyndra spectra
watt evergreens solar these are all I'd
say failed companies that by the
definition of failure bankruptcy I mean
by that metric so as United Airlines
failed in America
lines fail they're still around they
restructured under bankruptcy protection
some have closed their doors entirely
other ones have restructured or in the
process of restructuring why each of
these companies have failed different
reasons you can't claim that each one
had the exact same trajectory but you
can definitely point to certain market
conditions as influencing or
precipitating their failure let me be
more specific
these companies right here are all wafer
or thin film device and module
manufacturers they're the upstream
components right
these aren't installation companies
these aren't installers failing these
are upstream manufacturers failing and
and a few high-profile ones at that
so that was precipitated by the recent
market conditions the the capital crunch
it began with some of the companies
saying in opti solar in 2009 I believe
they were a company that was producing
amorphous silicon modules and as we
studied amorphous silicon the
efficiencies are low right the amorphous
silicon module efficiencies in the order
of six percent and they said well never
mind that our cost structure is a little
high we're gonna scale up like nobody's
business we're gonna ramp up
manufacturing capacity to over a
gigawatt and do it really really quick
and just by sheer scale alone we'll be
able to drive down costs and get us to
the point where we're competitive on a
cents per kilowatt-hour basis with
crystalline silicon there's a great
business plan in theory but what
happened to them was when they went out
to try to raise money they couldn't find
any right around 2008 it was the
beginning of the financial crisis right
so they had the business plan in mind
and a paper it looked great but when it
came time to raise the funding to grow
they didn't have it and even though they
had a guaranteed customer PG&E that was
the Pacific Gas and Electric the
California utility they just could not
get the financing to expand their Kepler
their factory so what ended up happening
was they folded sold the the supply
stream if you will to first solar picked
it up for pennies on the dollar
and first solar modules ended up going
in the PG&E field installations instead
of the opti solar amorphous silicon each
company has its own story and have
failed for different reasons what's
clear is also there are more failed
upstart startups coming this is a time
of financial pain for them
the prices are very very low and there
are a few people who are tracking the
these startup companies I would say
erequests off from greentech media is
probably one of the most active in
publishing his his insights that said
there are many promising companies among
here and some of these hopefully will
become household names for good reasons
in the future as they have an innovation
that significantly drives down cost over
their competitors we're gonna get to
that in a few slides we're going to talk
about how to evaluate a company because
it's gonna be important for you
near-term because you might want a job
or you might want to form your own
company longer term because you might
become an investor in PV and you'll have
to figure out what types of companies
make sense to invest in in which don't
in terms of startup companies in New
England area we often think of ourselves
as kind of yeah maybe second fiddle to
Silicon Valley but there's a lot going
on in the region a lot of good work so
if you go to clean Energy Council org
and cluster map you'll see a map of the
local clean tech companies in the region
I'll leave this slide up there since I
see a few of you jotting notes it's it's
a it's a useful map and you can select
by sector as well if you look at solar
or look at biofuels and so forth all
right trends in renewable energy
manufacturing this slide is a little bit
outdated but it's the green tech media
research map of manufacturing in the
United States of the different solar
technologies again a bit outdated there
are few companies that have changed but
it gives you a sense of what the
distribution is what are the latest
trends of manufacturing the United
States the latest trends in
manufacturing if I were to point to a
few of them Mississippi has emerged as a
big manufacturing
state why what does what does the
southeast first off who's from the
southeast here
show of hands one two all right what do
you have in this region right around
here that the rest of the country
doesn't have I closed coal you have a
lot of coal you have nuclear as well
the TVA did anybody know what the TVA is
Tennessee Valley Authority right that's
a big public works project in fact that
got started and it provides low-cost
electricity to this entire region right
up here including northern Mississippi
including some of the northern portions
of the the far southeast States bottom
line you have depressed wages by and
large in these rural communities and
low-cost electricity which if labor in
and in utilities matter which it doesn't
solar manufacturing it's it's ripe for
manufacturing and you have many startup
companies staion
cally Solar Twin Creeks and others that
have moved into the Mississippi region
in very recent months for that region
for that reason you have let's see soon
IVA was based in Georgia Atlanta Ohio
still continues to be the North West as
well cheap hydro not exactly cheap wages
but bit cheap hydro and you know the
technologies do tend to stay closer to
the places where they were born you can
see in the San Francisco Bay Area
there's a propensity of to to form
startup companies and new technologies
as well as in the Massachusetts area so
these are focusing on some of the medium
scale manufacturers in terms of
manufacturing support this is what local
state governments are doing to help form
new companies in the United States you
have as well a variety of mechanisms
grants loans tax credits and so forth
for new factories that are trying to
start up so keep that in mind if you're
going for it and market incentives in
terms of the the the three Germany US
and China we also have to consider Korea
Japan
India Brazil other countries as well in
this mix if you really want a global
perspective but it's tums it down to
three in terms of what incentives are
available for different countries there
is a there is a plethora of different
incentives which can help the market
pull okay so we we go back and have a
clearer picture of what's happening at
least in the US with its investment the
VC investments as well as manufacturing
the next step on the state level so
we're collecting some data points there
so this this is interesting
if your money is from the bank let's say
and you're paying an interest rate on it
and you want to start a new factory but
then your local inspector comes back to
you and says well we're gonna have to
delay by three months because of reason
x y&z now you're paying interest on the
money potentially and but you're not
generating profits off of it right so
delays cost money the project delays
cost money it's also an opportunity cost
and so there was a study done a few a
few years ago looking into why why it is
that renewable energy projects are
delayed and they came up with some
interesting region region dependent
conclusions as a result of the study
whether it's transmission limitations
Texas they're even been cases in New
York of transmission lines having
limited capacity for renewables
financing constraints power purchase
agreement weaknesses permitting that
could be a big slowdown if that's not
streamlined financing and permitting and
negligible market local market and again
we see the the TVA popping up here as a
negligible market for the renewables
because well you have cheap electricity
it's hard to compete against that right
but in other states with more Sun and
more expensive electricity there there's
the potential to install it but you may
be limited in fact by the grid there was
a big new study released I believe it
was this week by the MIT Energy
Initiative on on the future of the grid
yeah
power purchase agreement so that's the
incentive mechanism that whereby you can
begin putting the solar panels on your
roof and the installer pays for the
panel's gets the money from the bank
installs them on your roof you sign the
contract to pay a certain price for the
electricity over the next 12 15 20 years
so global trends in R&D this is again a
data dump of several sources one from
the NSF showing industry aren't the
expenditures government federal
government and other you can see in the
United States this is across all sectors
here but really an inversion of the role
of industry and federal government right
so when you hear you MIT for instance
going after large companies and saying
hey you should invest in R&D here at MIT
this is one of the fundamental driving
forces right this is this inversion here
or the decline of federal government
spending and it as well as resulted in
an MIT looking elsewhere for funding not
only industry the greatest gains in R&D
intensity in terms of the R&D
expenditure have been in Asia now you
can see on the right-hand side of this
chart China Japan and Korea increasing
the expenditure from 1997 to 2007 this
was right before the financial crisis
hit in the US holding relatively
constant as a percentage as a share of
GDP science and science and engineering
interest in Asia
this is science and engineering degrees
as a percentage of new degrees you can
see over here we have Germany Korea and
China Germany makes a lot of sense the
Germans have about 44,000 engineering
jobs in renewables right now that are
unfilled right so they they need people
they need people to go to Germany to to
get high-tech jobs China is is is a bit
more precarious in the sense that the
supply and demand is much more evenly
matched and the growth of both are
increasing it
study rates so if the growth of
manufacturing and in R&D does not
continue to rise in China there's going
to be an oversupply of people and that
can lead to a number of problems and so
the the it's very important for China
over the next several years to keep a
strong steady handle on this growth to
make growth manageable it's a good
problem to have it's managing success
but it could also lead to some
catastrophic consequences if the system
gets out of balance in the United States
well I believe this data came from 2005
that was at the height of financial
engineering I would hope that this
number here is increased a bit since the
collapse of the financial markets and a
recognition that there are productive
ways of investing one's talents and
mental gifts global research output
shift towards Asia this is global
research R&D sheriff of science and
engineering articles so if you're
starting from a small amount and growing
you're going to be by if you if you just
look at in a percentage basis by
necessity taking away a share of the pie
from another entity so as China grows
India grows the rest of the world grows
the share of articles science and
engineering articles in the US and EU
begins to drop essentially the dominant
players and in Japan as well now that's
not necessarily a bad thing if the
quality of the articles is maintained
and the total number of articles
continues to expand and we have the
capacity to keep up with the information
right so there's a there's a threshold
or a limit to how much we can absorb how
much information new information we
could absorb per unit time so people are
working on more sophisticated ways of
gathering and assembling this
information especially using computers
nowadays that can help expedite Rd so a
number of trends happening on the
scientific side you're involved with
that high-tech trade balances continue
to widen this is the the trade balance
and techni high-technology goods US and
china and so the the
obviously Chinese economy trending away
from well still heavily invested in raw
materials but trending away from that
toward high-tech manufactured goods in
the US entering a region of trade
deficit as a result of purchasing those
those products so these are all trends
that have policymakers in particular
concerned and and and looking at at the
future of global competitiveness
technology evaluation let me spend a
couple of words bringing all of what
I've just said and everything over the
entire course home to you so so far
we've talked about this these these
things in very etheral terms it's useful
information it will prove useful once
you begin applying it but we want to run
through a quick little scenario right
here where you're asked to evaluate a
new PV technology why well you might be
applying for a job at this company and
they say they have the greatest thing
since sliced bread
and you want to put on your thinking cap
and evaluate whether that's true or not
you might have a new idea or new
innovation and you're trying to make the
tough call
do I go forward and establish a company
off of this idea or do I have to go back
and turn the crank a few more times to
come up with the next better idea that's
more worthy of investment you could be
an investor now you could have money or
disposal and you could decide what
company to invest in or what not to
invest in so how do you go about this I
would say three fundamental components
and and venture capitalists might
disagree with me or other people who
have different skill sets might disagree
with me but me from this perspective as
an engineer I would say first analyze
the physics figure out how this
technology works right because if you
understand how the technology works you
can understand some of the fundamental
limitations you can understand
efficiency limits and you can predict
based on pattern recognition how hard is
it going to be to obtain or to approach
those limitations analyze the cost scale
scale potential meaning the potential to
scale up and manufacturing this is
really more on the engineering science
side and we've been getting more into
this during the second and third parts
of the course in analyze markets this is
definitely the third part of the course
so this begins to pull it all together
right let's start with analyzing the
physics we talked about conversion
efficiency being a strong lever for
cost this way we're analyzing conversion
efficiency the way I would recommend
analyzing any PV technology that they
throw at you would be thinking about
conversion efficiency in terms of output
energy versus input energy and think
about losses along each step of the way
if you have time with the R&D department
sit down with them sit down with some of
these the chief engineers and walk
through each of the steps going from a
light photon entering the the device to
charge being collected on the other side
with a certain current voltage
characteristic and keep in mind that the
total efficiency is going to be limited
by whatever the worst performer is and
keep that picture in mind to do big
advice customer needs the next is
analyzing what what makes your product
special right so where where is it going
to fit into the the big picture is it
going to run with the big dogs is it
going to be an on grid application in
which case cents per kilowatt hour
really matter the price for the
electricity for a power purchase
agreement if you're just selling the
module maybe dollars per watt would be
an important metric as well or are you
going into one of these other niche
markets right over here and are you
going to be a player there how big is
that market these are some questions to
ask cost all right so now that we know
what our intended market is we know what
our product is going to look like
we know the physics behind it we know in
a bit we'll know more about the
manufacturing we we think about cost and
we talked briefly about this during
class we had more of an in-depth
discussion with Doug that Excel
spreadsheet by the way will be available
to you so you can look through it and
see how a cost analysis was done for
crystalline silicon and how you might
adapt it to your technologies but it's
really important to perform a cost
performance model for your technology so
that you can understand what levers to
pull what levers need to be pulled to
increase your parameter of Merit
whatever that parameter of Merit happens
to be for your potential customer need
manufacturing technologies and scale
really do play into this quite a bit and
for many technologies or for many
companies in at least in the Silicon
Valley area there might be 50 companies
working on the same material cop
indium gallium diselenide let's say cigs
but they each have their own deposition
process and they're each trying to
develop their own pieces of equipment to
manufacture this material so
understanding the basic differences
between the different deposition systems
is important and we walk through that
during a thin films lecture so again you
have access to this information and you
can parse through it in greater detail
should you need to scaling of
manufacturing we talked about resource
availability we even had an in-class
debate about it about cadmium tellurium
there are reports out there which you
have access to like this ApS report on
critical energy materials and we
understand that the manufacturing and
reserves of these elements are not equi
distributed in fact they're concentrated
in certain regions of the world and so
that might influence the ultimate
potential of a certain technology to
scale and again this is another
intelligent question that you can set of
questions you can ask we understand a
bit about the market dynamics now we
understand this is price we understand
that there was a bit of a plateau in
price in the mid 2000s a precipitous
drop over the last three years and
that's really changed the way that
investments in equity look at the solar
market in the mid-2000s it was all
gangbusters everybody was really happy
to throw any money they had at solar now
people are a lot more selective in terms
of what they invest in and this is this
trend of oversupply under supply it's
probably going to continue for some time
if the integrated circuit industry is
any example and model so we're likely to
see this continue what is your market
timing it might be a really good time to
found an installation company right now
if you can scale and grow quickly and
you have the right niche but if you're
many if you have a new idea for a
thin-film absorber it's important to
think critically about where the market
is going to go over the next few years
and how that impacts your strategy as a
company you might decide well you know
markets kind of kind of cold right now
for four modules so why don't we hold
back on building that large-scale
manufacturing plant until say 2014 and
invest really heavily in R&D right now
and stay its small without the the
financial obligations
big manufacturing line until we really
nail the technology and have something
good to go and plus think about our exit
strategy maybe we won't ramp up to be a
gigawatt or two gigawatt company maybe
instead it's more important to form
partnerships with companies that are
manufacturing cad-tel or SIG's right now
so our business developer is going to
spend more time chatting with the
business developers of First Solar and
and other companies we also know a bit
about the financial incentives from
Germany and some of the largest PV
markets in the world we know that China
is going to ramp up significantly in
terms of installations over the next few
years we know that the United States
will as well as the the prices continue
to come down these are the PV feed-in
tariff rates shown in blue in red for
different types of installations blue
being the large freestanding systems the
red being mostly rooftop mounted systems
so we saw that the feed-in tariff rate
in Germany has come down versus time and
the average electricity price has gone
up so we can begin predicting what the
role of market subsidies will be when we
try to roll out our technology onto the
grid and we can plot this and and see
how that will impact our business model
as well and lastly we know that about 99
percent of the solar panels have yet to
be made right 99 percent of the solar
panels have yet to be made so there is a
lot of potential here this again going
back to the very first lecture where we
had new energy installations new PV
installations growing significantly
right convergence is coming whose going
to comprise who is going to bridge that
gap who is going to be the maker of the
technology that will ultimately bring PV
to a massive scale in the grid that's
for you to decide
so other intangibles in terms of
evaluating companies would include the
team especially the leadership team what
is their track record what is their
philosophy of running the company the
financing that's available how much cash
is at hand the patent portfolio how well
protected are they and and so forth
patents by the way variant importance
from the u.s. to certain other regions
of the world
it's
important in the US and Europe that's
important in China but it depends if a
certain idea is patented you will have
difficulty accessing that market you
will have difficulty selling product
into that market even though you can
continue to sell a mark that product
into markets that value patents less in
IP so let's go through a few examples
I'm gonna throw a couple of examples
that you real quick and just spout off
the first ideas that come to you how
would you analyze this company so our
paint alright so I have my big spray
paint system here and I go to the side
of the house and I go Shh and that saves
me a bundle on installation costs it's
easy you can do it yourself and you just
connect a few wires and voila you have
solar electricity what would be your
first instinct how does it work
bravo Bravo what is the physics behind
it how do you separate charge if you go
back to this right over here right light
absorption charge excitation it's
important or what
what's the band gap of the material how
how what what how does it excite charge
inside of the material
where's charge separated how do carriers
reach those separation points I mean
you're just spraying on one homogeneous
layer did I get that right
there's no like there's not like two
layers does it face separate how does
that work and in charge collection how
are you collecting the charge over that
massive area what are you resistive
losses and so forth so you're equipped
now to ask those questions as a result
of this course that's pretty awesome you
think about it you're pretty empowered
so you know it could work
solar paint could very well work so it's
important not to write in to this
discussion when a high horse and say
what work because of XYZ is important to
keep an open mind because new ideas are
really quite startling and and they can
be game-changing but it's important to
have a critical yet respectful approach
to this right a critical mind is always
a good thing to have in your shoulders
window material so I'm arriving to you
and I say this is the Wonder material
it's all earth-abundant totally scalable
but I'm not going to tell you what it is
so you're gonna have to invest in my
company because I have this great team
right here a great team coming from
Intel I used to be a head manager at a
National Laboratory I know my stuff I
read
my PV I can value with a few
presentations about PV device physics
and talk all this fancy stuff but you're
gonna have to invest in my team at my
company based on a few SEM images plain
view SEM images of the material
structure just to prove that I can
actually deposit it but I'm not going to
tell you what the material is because
you as VCS could have run off with my
idea then go sell it to somebody else so
I'm going to hold that very close to my
chest do you invest in me or not depends
on what you're asking depends how much
you're asking for that was a real
situation I was in that room I was
evaluating that company and as a
scientist in that room I was like are
you serious you can't be serious the
venture capitalists however thought
differently and said look the team is
really good and I I think you know for
reasons that were described I can't get
into all of them without giving the
details away there were reasons for
investing in that particular case in
that company and even though the physics
was not understood and even though the
ultimate efficiency potential was not
understood the VC firm made an
investment so far has been going okay
with that company so just to point out
that this is a base a foundation of
which to make decisions it's not a
prescription upon which to make
decisions right a lot of things factored
in use your best judgment you're the one
best equipped to to make those decisions
path forward this is kind of my last few
words on the soapbox before I hand over
the microphones to you the path forward
from my perspective the markets are
going to drive a lot of the public story
but you know that cost matters more than
price right prices the short term market
poll during the mid-2000s actually down
here when when the the price was still
very very high solar was kind of this
hippie a tree-hugging group of nerds
that would get together at the mi at the
muddy Charles and and come up with the
facts base analysis which form the MIT
energy Club really small thing and then
right when the prices began to
to stabilize and there was a this view
that energy was this huge goldmine
waiting to be explored a massive amount
of interest came into the field and
growth accordingly and it was good but
in the 2008 and so forth we had this
Versa pitous drop in prices as well as
the collapse of finance to allow these
technologies to scale up the valley of
death widened and deepened the bit if
you will and suddenly energy looked a
lot more precarious started having
students come into my office doing
interviews saying what sort of career
can I have here no tell me seriously are
there jobs waiting for me when I exit
the realities are jobs waiting for
bright smart people regardless of the
market condition there were jobs back
here there will be jobs in the future as
well if you're good at what you do and
you ask the right questions conducted
experiments know how to disseminate your
work but this is kind of a return to the
roots now where we have people who are
in solar and interested in solar who are
really there for the long run and so
knowing the market conditions really
helps you put everything into
perspective and see how how the
situation might evolve going forward in
terms of tipping point it's largely
agreed upon that a dollar a watt system
installed is is really where we want to
head to so we know the cost right now of
manufacturing a PV module crystalline
silicon is in the order of dollar per
watt and if you're venting a new
technology you have to do half of that
right and crystalline silicon has a
roadmap to get to about 50 cents per
watt peak by 2020 2025 and so if you're
developing the new technology you have
to undercut that in some way shape or
form and you can do that in a variety of
ways improving the efficiency there's a
lot of headroom in efficiency a lot of
headroom there may be a manufacturing
scale and so forth but if a technology
some technology by 2020 can get to $1 a
watt installed we're looking at by 2030
a pretty massive grid penetration of PV
across the United States and that's just
the start of it the u.s. is just the
drop in the bucket this is the world
there's a lot of people 1.6 billion of
them approximately without electricity
right now they're coming online and
they're driving the majority of the
both in co2 emissions majority the
growth comes from two points one we're
outsourcing our co2 right if you look at
the amount of co2 the United States
contributes to the world it might be 1/5
but if you look at all the manufactured
goods all the clothes were wearing right
now all of the apparatus that we're
using right these were manufactured
probably not in the US but they're here
for our consumption and use we own that
carbon that's our carbon we're
responsible for it so our footprint
increases further so we're outsourcing
the carbon it's it's growing in certain
developing regions that are exporting to
us and secondly they're also growing
they're also consuming they're also
getting cars and computers and so forth
so there's an overall growth of
consumption around the world we agree
that climate change is an issue and we
look at the solar insolation map and we
say wow compared to certain minerals or
rare earths or petroleum this is fairly
equitably distributed even regions say
in Patagonia are up in northern Europe
compared to the equator we're looking at
about a 3 X maybe a 4 X Delta in solar
resource not a million to 0 a million to
1 rather we're looking at a 4 X Delta in
solar resource which is not that big of
a spread and furthermore if we go back
and look at the countries that are
really coming online just using this
this loose parameter Human Development
Index that we refer to in the first day
of class we can see that the countries
with the largest solar resource base
several of them also happen to be
countries that are on the path toward
development on the path toward
consumption and solar can really have an
impact in those countries to improve the
quality of life and also reduce carbon
emissions overall in the world so what
role can you play I mean I think
important things to keep in mind is is
there's it we're really at the beginning
of solar but we have a lot of headroom
to grow I think the amount of venture
capital investment lost so far due to
failed companies is a drop in the bucket
compared to GDP is a drop in the bucket
compared to military investments is a
drop in the bucket the things that we
consider important and especially the
qual
life in the world so put it's important
to keep that in perspective we need to
maintain momentum capital innovation
culture that's what we have here it's
growing in other places around the world
as well that's important to foster that
growth and evolve into a global society
where we have connections and in shared
connections with with groups around the
world shared interests and can leverage
each other strengths the rest of the
world is catching it fast with increased
competition that's why isolation won't
work in this case we do need increased
R&D efforts on key targets I think
better investments and smarter choices
of technology is important and hopefully
over the course of the class you're
equipped with several of the tools to
make those types of decisions yourself
we also need to change the way we
innovate pooled resources collaborative
efforts improve industry University lab
relations which in the u.s. are somewhat
at a precarious state because of
differences in priorities between
publications and IP protection and so
forth direct to manufacturing
innovations instead of always thinking
that startup companies are the only
route thinking in terms of how do I get
this technology into a large established
company in the u.s. that's the route
that we don't think about very often but
could have a huge impact and certainly
has an impact in Germany the need for a
steady predictable market alright I
think might be asking too much in this
bullet point but it'd be nice and
certainly policy can play a large role
in that we have enough in predictability
with oversupply and other supply we
don't need the politicians getting into
it as well and changing their minds
every two years an investment in
education as well the right type of base
education so you can get involved in a
number of ways and I encourage you to do
so I thank you for your attention and I
wish you the best of fortunes going
forward please feel free to call on me
whenever you have a need and I look
forward to your presentation so be well
Thanks
you